but then we went to your Vegas show that
you set up and there was like ten people
there and that was half her family you
know what it was terrible but let me
explain why why because no because no
you're black and I'm glad you're telling
this your I drove all the way over there
because there's a lot of comics and if
you want to get personal and real on
your show yeah there's a lot of comments
that come up to us and ask us how how do
you get to that that place that you're
at well this is what I did I rented out
that theater because no one was in Vegas
they didn't have open mikes like you did
like if you want to go play catch a
rising star you had to be a headliner
from LA
you have to play seven days yeah yeah
yeah so I went to UNLV and and my cousin
Mona was kind of like a alumni there she
was a cheerleader for the running rebels
back you know so she goes I know the the
Filipino Association they'll rent out
that that room for you for free I mean
and I told them I got these Asian come
comics and it would be great to like
show support for Asian comics that are
coming up the show be free just let us
you rent it out for us and she'll be
free to the students uh-huh and they go
do you know they said no did you tell
anybody about the show though oh you're
not listening to the story like I get it
you want to go to the punchline and
that's why you're still here there's an
artist or Eaton there's ingredients in
go ahead go tell go for Luther he's bomb
holes do this low burn yeah so uh I they
said no and it was the Filipino studio
Student Association they said no to me
and I was like really it better get it
laughs at the end this [ __ ] story
though there is no story it's just
inspirational are Arabs and I'm gonna
tell you what happened there better be a
payoff there girl then I was dating the
girl I was dating white girl she's my
friend
she was cute yeah Jennifer and Josh and
she had a co-worker that was actually
going to that school and he was in a
frat white boy all white guys yeah and
he goes I'll rent it out what's the big
deal and he signed the waiver hmm he
signed the waiver and the only people
that came to that show and I even went
back to the Filipino Student Association
and I said hey I got someone to run to
for us can you at least come in support
and they still didn't support they still
didn't come and no I came I put fliers
all over the school and the only people
that came was at that fraternity and
they brought their
sorority remember that and there was
like maybe 15 yeah yeah yeah my dad came
and anything that's the grind though and
that and I was still able to pay you
because I went to all these local
businesses and I made a program and I
made sponsors that's how I was able to
pay you so yeah is that I didn't care
that it was empty I was happy that we
were on stage and asking is that the end
of the story and then I had to know I
know your your show should have some
kind of inspiration and in the middle of
the guy that's the thing though actually
the Filipinos didn't yes so crazy yeah
no Asians showed up but you got to
remember the time frame Bobby and I were
kind of like kind of like the topic
comers like no one's really seen like
yet enough asian comics before like now
there's a lot but back then it was
literally just Bobby and I'm Margaret
Cho and Henry Cho are like the ones that
were kind of like the headliners out I
mean literally there was no one I mean
it's like I remember this is before
Bobby got premium blend this is before
Bobby got MADtv this is just Bobby like
like nobody I don't know anybody
no you weren't open my career you were
like I was like a crowd favorite at La
Jolla everyone was always open mike
[ __ ]
no it's not man yeah to other comics you
were kind of like legend like there was
a tall [ __ ] that's Bobby Lee there's no
reason your ass
[Laughter]
[Music]